- SO ON THIS SAD,
AND YET HAPPY DAY,
LET'S ALL RAISE A GLASS
TO CELEBRATE THE RETIREMENT
OF EVERYONE'S FAVORITE
PARK RANGER,
THE GLUE THAT HELD US ALL
TOGETHER FOR SO MANY YEARS,
TO...
HAROLD.
- WHO THE [bleep] IS HAROLD?
- I'VE NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
- WOODY PUT HIM ON LOOKOUT DUTY
IN THE FIRE TOWER 20 YEARS AGO
AND FORGOT TO RELIEVE HIM.
- SO HE SPENT TWO DECADES
BY HIMSELF IN A SMALL TOWER?
- WOW, HE'S LUCKY
HE DIDN'T GO NUTS.
- YOU'RE THE DEVIL.
I WILL BURN YOU!
[high-pitched]
YOU GOT TO CATCH ME FIRST.
[laughs demonically]
- TEQUILA SUNRISE,
HOLD THE SUNRISE.
[glass shatters]
- IT'S ON THE HOUSE.
- WELL, AREN'T YOU A SWEETHEART.
- DO YOU REALLY THINK
THE BARTENDER
JUST GAVE YOU A FREE DRINK
BECAUSE HE'S A SWEETHEART?
- YEAH, WHY ELSE?
- BECAUSE YOUR PANTS
ARE SO TIGHT,
I CAN READ THE MILEAGE
ON YOUR VAGINA.
- THAT IS SO SEXIST.
I DON'T GET PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT BECAUSE OF MY LOOKS.
HE GIVES OUT DRINKS
BECAUSE HE'S A NICE GUY.
- CAN I GET A GLASS
OF TAP WATER?
- BEAT IT, SEA WORLD.
[uplifting music]